have you ever seen someone surf in CS go
and thought what is that surfing dates
back to CS 1.6 and was accidentally
discovered by a modder named marioned
while messing around in a custom map on
this Rift Hub when climbing one of these
to reach a gun that his friend fell off
the side and slid to his dad and from
this accident surfing the Counter-Strike
was born first run jump and air strafe
onto a descending slope depending on
which side you're looking to land you're
going to want to either hold a or D and
move it into the side of that surface if
the slope is on your left strafe left if
it's on your right strafe right the goal
is to gain enough velocity that you can
launch from one slope to another the
trick is to keep strafing left or right
at all times even when Airborne to keep
momentum the best tip I can give a
beginner is to never press W and only
strafe sideways does it help your
movement
eh not really but it's super fun